la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique
de la précédente séance a été distribuée
et bien
il n'y a pas d'observation je n'en vois
pas le procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement je vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmise en direct sur
Public Sénat et sur notre site internet
au nom du bureau du Sénat j'appelle
chacun de vous mes chers collègues à
observé au cours de nos échanges l'une
des valeurs essentielles du Sénat le
respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou de celui du temps
de parole et si l'on pouvait s'écouter
dans un relatif silence ce serait
magnifique
merci
la parole est au président Guillaume
gonta pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire vous avez la
parole chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre j'avais prévu de vous
interpeller avec véhémence pour dénoncer
les manœuvres auxquelles ce livre votre
gouvernement et vos alliés pour empêcher
un vote en séance pénière de l'Assemblée
nationale un vote ne serait-ce que
symbolique sur le report de la jegal de
la retraite mais au regard des
événements consternants advenu ce matin
à l'Assemblée c'est avec une profonde
gravité que je m'adresse à vous
madame la Première ministre les droits
des oppositions politiques sont le
fondement même de la démocratie c'est à
l'aune de ses droits qu'on juge la
qualité d'une démocratie notre pays à
tous les échelons national ou locaux
fait déjà pas le figure avec une
hypertrophie des pouvoirs exécutifs et
des assemblées réduites à leur seule
fonction tribunicienne pour tous nos
partenaires européens régime
parlementaire rompu à la négociation et
à une certaine culture du compromis
notre régime politique est une
incongruité pour ne pas dire une
aberration dernière preuve en date de
culture politique très différente le
Premier ministre espagnol Pedro Sanchez
remet son mandat en jeu après avoir
perdu une élection municipale rien de
tel chez nous ou le gouvernement avance
en écrasant toute contestation devant
lui ce matin c'est bien plus que la
bataille de retraite qui est jouée à
l'Assemblée nationale en torpillant une
initiative parlementaire de l'opposition
en bafouant le droit d'amendement en
performant le corset de l'article 40 en
véritable étau vous créez un précédent
délétère qui menace de réduire à néant
le droit d'expression déjà famélique des
parlementaires madame la Première
ministre vous êtes une démocrate vous
l'avez clamé ici même en juillet 2022
comment pouvez-vous tolérer la dérive
autoritaire dans laquelle le président
vous enferme
merci
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Gontard
je suis souvent surprise d'entendre les
mêmes qui se disent défenseur du
Parlement être les premiers à refuser
les règles
monsieur le Président Gontard
revenons-en au fait l'examen de la
réforme des retraites a eu lieu avec 175
heures de débat parlementaires elle a
été votée par deux fois par le Sénat et
le Conseil constitutionnel s'est
prononcer très clairement sur la
conformité de l'essentiel du texte à
notre Constitution et sur le rejet de
deux demandes de référendum d'initiative
partagée qui visait à l'abroger la
proposition de doigt dont vous parlez
qui fait actuellement l'objet d'un
examen par la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale
aggraverait considérablement les charges
publiques et réduirait les recettes cela
contrevient de façon évidente à
l'article 40 de notre Constitution
ce texte vous le savez monsieur le
Président est anticonstitutionnel et
personne n'est dupe de la manœuvre qui
se joue et monsieur le Président Gothard
vous appelez au respect du Parlement au
débat jour je vous renvoie à ces
principes ce matin la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale a voté et à supprimer
l'article de la proposition de loi qui
visait à abroger la réforme des
retraites c'est un vote clair et
démocratique mais immédiatement après la
nupesse a répondu par l'obstruction avec
le dépôt de 3000 sous amendements pour
empêcher un vote final en commission
la réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction de mon côté
je crois en notre Constitution et je
respecte le travail du Parlement alors
je souhaite que l'examen de la
proposition de loi puisse aller à son
terme dans de bonnes conditions et que
le contrôle de la recevabilité des
amendements puissent exercer normalement
dans la sérénité en somme je ne souhaite
qu'une chose le respect de nos règles et
du débat parlementaire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président gantard 14
secondes madame la Première ministre
d'abord l'obstruction c'est vous toutes
les règles tordre les règles ce n'est
pas appliquer les règles madame le
Premier ministre vous pouvez entrer dans
l'histoire en ouvrant une page nouvelle
de notre république parlementaire vous
auriez entrerez hélas comme une
Fossoyeuse de la démocratie française
allez allez on se calme
la parole
la parole est maintenant madame Colette
mélo pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoire vous avez la
parole chers collègues
je ne serai pas là demain ce sont les
derniers mots de l'Insee présent
adressée par message à l'une de ses
camarades de classe le 12 mai dernier
Lindsay a décidé de mettre fin à ses
jours parce que la vie lui était devenue
insupportable 13 ans c'est normalement
l'âge de l'insouciance et de la joie de
vivre mais pour elle c'était l'enfer
parce qu'en groupe d'élèves l'art cela
est au collège et sur les réseaux
sociaux avec une violence inouïe
l'Insee vient ainsi compléter une liste
déjà beaucoup trop longue chaque année
près d'un million d'élèves sont victimes
de harcèlement scolaire et une vingtaine
d'entre eux commet l'irréparable madame
la ministre il faut que cela cesse
avec ma collègue Sabine Vaneck qui vit
ce drame dans son département nous avons
remis notre rapport sénatorial sur ce
sujet à Monsieur monsieur papendiye
ministre de l'éducation nationale ce
rapport comprend 35 préconisations
autour de trois priorités prévenir
détecter les cas et les traiter
systématiquement et sans délais madame
la ministre la situation est urgente dès
qu'en cas de harcèlement apparaît c'est
immédiatement que tous les acteurs
concernés doivent agir sans minimiser
les situations le cyber-harcèlement fait
son Stone œuvre très rapidement en
démultipliant les conséquences graves
l'enfant n'ayant plus de répit même dans
la sphère privée le programme phare a le
mérite d'exister mais il est
malheureusement encore loin d'être
appliqué dans tous les établissements
malgré tous les efforts déployés force
est de constater que tout n'est pas mis
en oeuvre pour sauver les enfants
victimes de harcèlement dans le cas de
l'Insee la situation était parfaitement
connue dans l'établissement mais quelle
est cette jeune fille a-t-elle reçu
a-t-on vraiment tiré les leçons des
drames précédents madame la ministre
quelle mesure concrète comptez-vous
mettre à neuf immédiatement merci
la parole est à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement de la formation
professionnelle vous avez la parole
madame la ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice collecte Colette mélo
permettez-moi tout d'abord d'adresser
tout mon soutien et toutes mes pensées à
la famille de Lindsay nous avons fait
vous le savez de la lutte contre le
harcèlement une priorité et je sais
madame la sénatrice que nous partageons
ce combat et que vous êtes impliqué sur
ce sujet depuis longtemps vous le savez
nous concentrons tous nos efforts pour
lutter contre ce fléau délictualisations
du harcèlement généralisation du plan
phare dans toutes les écoles primaires
les collèges et dès la rentrée 2023 et
dans tous les lycées formation de très
grandes ampleur pour tous les personnels
à la prévention à la détection et à la
prise en charge du harcèlement diffusion
large des numéros verts 36 18 et 36 19
et le ministre a annoncé très récemment
une procédure spécifique décret qui
viendra en juillet pour déplacer l'élève
harceleur comme l'avait proposé madame
la sénatrice Marie Mercier et pourtant
oui nous sommes de nouveau face à un
drame depuis le suicide de l'Insee à
l'automne dernier la mère de l'Insee
avait interpellé la direction de
l'établissement parce que l'INSEE était
victime de violence et de moquerie de la
part d'une autre élève de son collègue
cet élève avait fait l'objet d'une
exclusion de trois jours puis en raison
d'une récidive cet élève avait été
définitivement fin février de ce collège
ensuite il semblait que la saison la
situation s'était apaisée mais le
cyber-harcèlement que vous évoquez à
continuer à l'abri des regards et du
contrôle des adultes et des personnels
enseignants c'est un sujet fondamental
sur lequel nous devons continuer à
travailler vous l'avez largement
souligné dans votre rapport sur le
harcèlement et ce n'est que trois jours
avant ce geste fatal que l'équipe du
collège a de nouveau été alerté pour la
situation de l'Insee mais cela n'a pas
suffi aujourd'hui des poursuites pénales
sont engagées quatre adolescents et un
adulte ont été mis en examen du côté de
l'éducation nationale le ministre a
missionné l'inspection générale pour
mener une enquête administrative sachez
madame la sénatrice que l'éducation
nationale et ses personnels mettent tout
en oeuvre pour éviter ces drames restons
tous solidaires et mobilisés contre ce
fléau je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est maintenant au
président Bruno Retailleau pour le
groupe les républicain
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues c'était vous madame la
Première ministre que je veux m'adresser
et à travers vous au président de la
République pour soutenir ici dans cette
mission une cause juste la cause d'un
petit peuple oublié un peuple qui a fait
l'objet il y a plus d'un siècle d'un
génocide et un peuple qui est
aujourd'hui au prises avec une tentative
dépuration ethnique culturelle et
religieuse comme vous le savez depuis
près de six mois
l'Azerbaïdjan bloque le corridor de la
Chine qui relie ce petit territoire à
l'Arménie et il fait donc il transforme
le ok Rabat en prison à ciel ouvert dès
le mois de février le 22 février la Cour
de justice internationale
assommer la servadjan de lever le blocus
parce que le blocus met en danger la vie
de 120 000 Arméniens
donc 30000 enfants et c'est dans ces
conditions dans ce contexte que
l'Arménie défaite par la guerre des 44
jours le sabre sous la gorge sa
souveraineté désormais mise en jeu
menacé son intégrité territoriale aussi
pourrait envisager d'abandonner le
hautbarque dans ces conditions de
question et ces deux questions je
voudrais aussi associer dans un geste
trans partisan mon collègue Gilbert Luc
de vinasse qui préside le groupe
d'amitié franco-arméniens première
question la France a toujours fait du
principe d'autodétermination des peuples
un principe cardinal pour le haut
karabaque comme pour toute sa politique
étrangère est-ce toujours le cas
deuxième question l'épuration ethnique
n'a jamais été aussi imminente question
qu'allez-vous faire pour la prévenir
pour l'empêcher
merci
la parole
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bruno Retailleau la France avec
ses partenaires et pleinement engagé en
faveur des réglement durable du conflit
entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan nous
suivons la situation avec la plus grande
attention et je sais votre mobilisation
sur ce sujet monsieur le Président la
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères s'est rendues dans la région
fin avril pour appeler les parties à
reprendre les discussions qui étaient
alors bloquées aujourd'hui sous l'égide
de l'Union européenne les négociations
de paix reprennent c'est un signal
encourageant et nous saluons le rôle
actif des États-Unis avec qui nous nous
coordonnons étroitement
monsieur le Président Retailleau notre
pays est engagé au plus haut niveau pour
la paix dans la région demain en marge
du sommet de la communauté politique
européenne de kishinao le président de
la République sera aux côtés du
chancelier Scholtz et de Charles Michel
pour une réunion avec le Premier
ministre arménien et le président
azerbaïdjanais il existe aujourd'hui une
voie pour la paix elle passe par la
reconnaissance mutuelle de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale des deux pays elle passe
par la délimitation de la frontière
commune et nous saluons à cet égard les
déclarations du Premier ministre
arménien Nicole pachinian dans ce
conflit la France n'oublie pas les
enjeux humanitaires et les conséquences
du blocage persistants du corridor de la
Chine nous n'avons eu de cesse de
rappeler la nécessité de mettre en œuvre
la décision de la Cour internationale de
justice du 22 février
plus particulièrement Monsieur le
Président retaillau vous avez raison
d'évoquer les droits et garanties des
populations du haut-karaba qui doivent
pouvoir vivre en paix et en sécurité
vous pouvez compter sur le plein
engagement de la France pour continuer à
trouver des solutions durables et à la
paix dans la région je vous remercie
merci
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre je sais
l'engagement de la France je sais je
reconnais l'engagement du président de
la République mais aujourd'hui nous
devons faire plus on doit faire plus
parce qu'on est à la veille d'une
tragédie on doit faire plus parce que on
le doit aux Arméniens à ce peuple frère
avec lequel nous partageons tant de
notre histoire des liens des liens
d'affection autant que des liens de
civilisation les maladies de Charles
Aznavour les compositions de Michel
Legrand les films d'Henri vergnold dont
le prénom était hashion et puis aussi
l'héroïsme de Manouchian qui bientôt
sans doute entrera par la grande porte
dans le potéon c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons faire encore
beaucoup plus merci nous avons des
devoirs et ça nous oblige madame la
première fois
[Applaudissements]
il y a des questions il y a des
questions plus importantes peut-être
plus difficile la parole est maintenant
Madame Nathalie Goulet pour le groupe
Union centriste vous avez la parole
chers collègues merci monsieur le
Président voilà une question difficile
en effet vous avez monsieur le ministre
Attal vous avez présenté hier votre plan
de lutte contre la fraude sociale je
souhaite d'abord vous remercier de
convenir que la fraude sociale est une
réalité est une fraude au finance
publique à traiter comme tel je fais ce
rappel dans ton plus volontiers que j'ai
été traité de menteuse dans cette
hémicycle et suppo du rassemblement
national par un ministre votre majorité
quand j'avais évoqué ce sujet il y a
quelques années quatre ans plus tard de
graves dysfonctionnements demeure les
fraudes sont évalués à 6 à 8 milliards
frochettes basses la Cour des comptes
relève le taux important de fraude
documentaire et demande la sécurisation
d'immatriculation des bénéficiaires
faute de sécurisation nous constr vous
construisez sur du sable vous présentez
des mesures ponctuelles utiles mais vous
abandonnez la voix de la biométrie votez
deux fois ici au Sénat pour un système
de fusion entre la carte nationale
d'identité et la carte Vitale il y
aurait en tenton des voies divergentes
au sein du gouvernement pour cet outil
dont la mise en chantier prendra des
années pouvez-vous nous donner monsieur
le ministre le calendrier de la mise en
place de cette mesure et justifier votre
choix quand on connaît le temps qu'il
faut aujourd'hui en France pour avoir
une carte nationale d'identité merci
chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Nathalie Goulet la lutte
contre la fraude sociale comme la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale et fondamentale
et quand on parle de lutter contre la
fraude sociale on parle tout simplement
de garder le contrôle sur notre modèle
social en reprenant le contrôle de ce
qu'on donne et à qui on le donne et je
voudrais commencer ma réponse en vous
remerciant vous avez travaillé depuis de
nombreuses années sur ce sujet vous avez
commis un rapport très important en 2019
avec ma collègue Carole Grandjean qui
était député à l'époque vous avez
participé au groupe de travail que j'ai
mis en place pour les laboration de ce
plan et plusieurs mesures de mon plan
viennent directement de propositions que
vous aviez émise j'en cite une à partir
du 1er juillet prochain nous ne
verserons plus d'allocations sociales
sur des comptes bancaires étrangers
c'est vous qui aviez fait cette
proposition et nous l'avons reprises
vous m'interrogez sur la carte Vitale
biométrique c'est une proposition
effectivement qui a été émise à
plusieurs reprises ici même nous avons
confié à l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales et à l'Inspection
générale des finances une mission sur le
sujet le rapport a été remis à quelques
jours il est à votre disposition que dit
ce rapport un ça coûterait très très
cher 250 millions d'euros par an
de il y a de vrais freins juridiques et
la CNIL s'opposent à cette mesure 3 il y
a des freins pratiques les syndicats de
médecins dans le rapport disent
eux-mêmes qu'il s'y oppose et par
ailleurs il y a des fins pratiques
aujourd'hui si vous êtes cloué au lit
que vous envoyez votre proche cherchez
vos médicaments à la pharmacie si vous
donnez donnez si vous devez donner vos
empreintes pour avoir vos médicaments
convenait que c'est assez compliqué la
mission
IGAS ignf recommande une autre voie de
sécurisation de la carte vitale en
faisant migrer la carte Vitale sur la
carte d'identité et c'est cette voix que
nous avons décidé de poursuivre ça
permettra de lutter davantage contre la
fraude à l'identité pour l'accès aux
soins dans notre pays par exemple à
travers du tourisme médical illégal nous
venons de lancer avec Gérald Darmanin et
François Brown une mission de
préfiguration pour déterminer le
calendrier et les modalités l'objectif
c'est d'aller vite mais évidemment qu'il
n'y ait pas de rupture dans l'accès aux
soins et aux droits pour les Français on
sait qu'il y a des difficultés
aujourd'hui pour renouveler ces titres
d'identité évidemment un tel chantier
une telle bascule ne peut s'envisager
tant qu'on n'est pas revenu à la normale
même si la première ministre a annoncé
des moyens très importants pour qu'on
puisse revenir à des délais normaux donc
la mission de préfiguration sera lancée
d'ici à l'été et les propositions nous
seront remises merci Madame Golay
oui monsieur ministre vous savez qu'il y
a des mesures urgentes à faire vous
n'êtes pas sans ignorer qu'il n'y a
absolument pas de lien par exemple entre
le titre de séjour en France et les
droits sociaux vous avez quelqu'un dont
le titre de séjour expire et dont la
carte Vitale continue à fonctionner vous
avez aussi dans le rapport de la Cour
des comptes du 24 mai un chiffre un peu
étonnant de 58 millions de cartes
vitales actives ce qui fait un surnombre
de 2 millions virgule 6 alors que
l'administration a refusé de fournir à
la Cour des comptes le nombre de cartes
vitales actif par année de naissance qui
permettrait évidemment de contrôler
l'exactitude de ces cartes vous avez
également 44000 frauduleux vous avez un
fichier âgé bref pour les étrangers
remplacés par l'administration numérique
des étrangers en France qui ne
fonctionnent pas dans la cour dit que
c'est toujours pas opérationnel
c'est-à-dire que vous avez un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements majeur il
faut absolument les régler sinon votre
plan ne sert à rien merci
la parole
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Pierre
ouzulias pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme tous les ans
presque 900 000 candidats ont soumis non
sans angoisse leur veut à la procédure
parcoursup comme tous les ans depuis
2018 nombreux sont ceux qui
s'interrogent sur les modalités les
critères et finalement l'intelligibilité
des conditions d'examen des dossiers par
certains établissements il est admis par
exemple que certaines filières réalisent
une première sélection des dossiers par
le seul usage d'un algorithme en outre
comme la révélé la Cour des comptes 20%
des commissions d'évaluation intègrent
dans leurs critères celui du lycée
d'origine certaines d'entre elles
pourraient même pondérer les notes du
contrôle continu par le rang de
classement de celui-ci ce qui pénalise
les élèves issus des établissements des
communes populaires notre groupe s'est
opposé à cette sélection qui est imposée
par le manque de place et le
sous-investissement chronique dans
l'université nous estimons à l'inverse
que la France à l'impériot devoir de
former plus d'ingénieurs plus de
techniciens et plus de diplômés de
l'université pour affronter les défis
climatiques technologiques et sociaux
mais dans l'immédiat considérons avec la
Commission européenne le Conseil
constitutionnel la Cour des comptes le
Défenseur des droits le comité d'éthique
de parcoursup et la commission de la
culture du Sénat qu'il est impérieux de
présenter de façon explicite aux
candidats les procédures d'examen de
leur dossier certains établissements ont
usé et abusé d'une dérogation
législative discutable pour s'affranchir
de l'obligation faite à tous les agents
publics de rendre compte de son
administration comment pouvons-nous
reprocher au gafam et à Tik Tok de nous
cacher leurs algorithmes et accepter
l'opacité de ce parcoursup merci
monsieur le Président merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Sylvie
Retailleau ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Ouzoulias alors d'abord je
voudrais vous dire combien je partage
avec vous cet ardente et je dis bien
ardente obligation de la transparence en
particulier quand il s'agit de l'avenir
de nos jeunes non pas parce que nos
enseignants profiteraient de l'opacité
pour pouvoir faire de la sélection
discriminante mais parce que la
transparente était la transparence
pardon est effectivement le levier un
levier pour accompagner en particulier
une meilleure orientation pour nos
jeunes mais aussi un levier pour rendre
les résultats de parcoursup plus
prévisible et donc diminuer le stress
pour les étudiants les élèves et leurs
familles alors depuis cinq ans que
faisons-nous et bien depuis cinq ans
l'amélioration continue de parcoursup
accompagne cette meilleure compréhension
de ces critères que vous appelez les
critères d'analyse de nos formations là
où il n'y avait rien nous avons expliqué
les attendus et oui nous avons rendu
obligatoire l'affichage des critères
pour cette session 2023 nous avons été à
l'écoute puisque nous avons refondu
complètement la manière dont sont
présentés ces critères pour apporter
effectivement une information plus
précise plus transparente aux candidats
toutes les formations de parcoursup
incluant les classes préparatoires
devront produire aussi en fin d'année un
rapport sur les critères utilisés et ce
rapport sera rendu public sur la
plateforme approfondir la transparence
c'est évident aimer c'est aussi
préserver le secret des délibérations
collégiales des enseignants ce n'est pas
un réflexe corporatif ou une volonté de
sauvegarde de l'opacité c'est la
convection que la délibération des
enseignants que l'on connaît parce que
je voudrais insister sur le caractère
humain de parcoursup qui a été reconnu
par le Conseil constitutionnel dans sa
décision de 2020 et la garantie d'un
regard humain derrière parcoursup il y a
des commissions d'examens il y a des
enseignants qui travaillent et je
voudrais profiter de cette occasion pour
réinsister sur le travail à tous niveaux
de nos collègues je finirai par dire que
je sais que demain s'ouvre la période
pour nos étudiants leurs familles de des
résultats des voeux et je voudrais leur
dire que l'on pense à eux que je pense à
eux et que tout est fait pour les
accompagner merci
de penser à eux mais si possible dans
les deux minutes allez monsieur
ouzoullias une poignée de seconde
poignée
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre c'est un discours que j'entends
depuis 2018 il faudrait que maintenant
les choses changent l'université était
un service public il faut que votre
ministère se donne les moyens d'examiner
l'établissement établissement les
conditions dans lequel est réalisée
cette sélection merci monsieur le
Président merci
la part et maintenant Monsieur Bernard
buis pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
vous avez la parole chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics lundi dernier vous avez annoncé
un vaste plein de lutte contre la fraude
sociale fraude multiformes évaluée à 11
milliards d'euros qui rassemblent aussi
bien les cotisations sociales et l'udées
la fraude aux prestations de santé ou
aux allocations sociales la fusion de la
carte Vitale avec la nouvelle carte
nationale d'identité mesure phare de
votre nouveau plan soulève plusieurs
interrogations tant sur sa mise en
oeuvre technique que sur la protection
des données déjà adoptée par plusieurs
pays européens dans la Suède le Portugal
ou la Belgique cette carte d'identité
électronique hybride permettrait
pourtant de renforcer des contrôles afin
de résorber les fraudes aux prestations
sociales
vous avancez également que dans 70% des
cas la fraude prestation de santé est à
l'initiative d'un professionnel par le
biais de surfacturation ou de
facturation d'actes l'an dernier
l'assurance maladie aurait ainsi détecté
300 millions d'euros de fraude vous
chiffrez également les arrêts maladie
dit de complaisance à 30 millions
d'euros entre 2017 et 2022 par
conséquent monsieur le ministre quels
sont les moyens que vous comptez
déployer pour détecter et lutter contre
ces prescriptions abusives merci pour
vos réponses la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bernard buis oui vous avez
raison la lutte contre la fraude sociale
nécessite des moyens c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai annoncé un
renforcement des effectifs de contrôle
de l'ordre de 20% sur les 5 prochaines
années et un investissement massif dans
les systèmes d'information un milliard
d'euros pour moderniser les systèmes
d'information des caisses de sécurité
sociale sur les 5 années qui viennent et
il y a du chemin à parcourir j'étais
d'ailleurs c'était une recommandation
qui m'avait été faite
en Belgique pour rencontrer la Banque
Carrefour de la sécurité sociale on voit
à quel point leur système de données
sont plus performants j'étais hier à la
Caisse nationale d'allocations
familiales on m'a présenté un dossier
tout à fait édifiant dans le département
du Val-de-Marne 437 dossiers de
non-conformité identifiés il s'agissait
venant de Roumanie de personnes qui
avaient fait des fausses déclarations de
résidence des fausses déclarations de
salariés en France 8 millions d'euros de
préjudice sur le seul département du
Val-de-Marne via le numérique on doit
renforcer nos outils de détection et de
sanctions
investissement que j'ai annoncé sur la
question des de la fraude aux
prescription de santé que vous avez
évoqué c'est une réalité dans notre pays
il ne faut pas stigmatiser évidemment
l'écrasante majorité la quasi-totalité
des professionnels de santé font les
choses dans les règles et donne de leur
temps pour les autres et pour leur
passion mais il y a des fraudes l'an
dernier nous avons des conventionné 5
centres de santé notamment dentaires et
en ophtalmo qui surfacturait à
l'Assurance Maladie un certain nombre
d'actes qui en réalité n'avaient pas été
réalisé auprès de patients et donc j'ai
annoncé dans le plan un dispositif nous
allons faire en sorte que désormais
quand des Français des patients sortent
d'un centre de santé il reçoit
automatiquement par SMS la liste des
actes qui ont été
facturés à l'assurance maladie par le
centre de santé si ils se rendent compte
qu'il y a des actes qui ne l'auront pas
été réalisés ils pourront le signaler
avec un bouton de signalement ce qui
permettra à l'Assurance Maladie
d'orienter ces contrôles vers les
centres de santé ou les professionnels
pour lesquels il y a le plus de
suspicion de fraude voilà une mesure
parmi d'autres vous avez raison comme
vous je considère qu'il faut lutter
implacablement contre ces fraudes c'est
ce que nous faisons avec mes collègues
du gouvernement évidemment François
Brown Jean-Christophe conte
singulièrement sur les prestations
sociales et l'assurance maladie et je
sais pouvoir compter sur votre soutien
merci monsieur le ministre pour ses
moyens annoncés qui je l'espère et nous
l'espérons tous permettront de lutter
contre cette fraude sociale qui gangrène
notre pays
merci
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Bernard Chaumier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président avant de
poser ma question je voudrais saluer
madame la Première ministre pour ses
propos concernant pétains et le
rassemblement national
certes la politique ne se résume pas des
positions morales mais celles-ci eu
égard à votre fonction et en particulier
à votre histoire personnelle mérite le
respect
ma question sera simple
un protocole thérapeutique a été mis en
oeuvre jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 dans
notre pays portant sur 30 000 personnes
et en violation flagrante de la loi
protégeant les personnes soumises à une
recherche médicale c'est un fait inédit
et c'est un fait grave sans précédent
alors Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi une
telle inertie des pouvoirs publics face
à ce scandale pourquoi a-t-il fallu tant
de temps pour que se déclenche enfin une
action et on l'a vu ce matin pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas pris les mesures
pour mettre fin à ce scandale et que
comptez-vous faire maintenant
merci
la parole est à Monsieur François Bonn
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
monsieur le sénateur Bernard Chaumier
nous parlons ici d'une étude qui a été
présentée en préprint c'est-à-dire qui
n'est pas encore accepté par des revues
scientifiques heureusement devrais-je
dire qui porte sur 30 000 patients qui
ont été traités à l'Institut hospitalo
universitaire Marseille Méditerranée
pour dire les mots en dehors de tout
cadre d'expérimentation clinique en
dehors de tout cadre d'utilisation des
médicaments puisqu'ils étaient utilisés
hors
am autorisation de mise sur le marché
alors concernant cette cette institut en
plus médicament je tiens à le préciser
qui avait déjà fait la preuve de leur
inefficacité dans le cadre du traitement
de la cote 19
par rapport à cette situation une
enquête
IgA igesr nous a rendu ses conclusions
en septembre 2022 à ma collègue Sylvie
retaillot et moi-même nous avons
immédiatement saisi le procureur de la
République de Marseille par le biais de
deux articles 40 devant la constatation
dans cette enquête de pratique aussi
bien managériale que de suivi des études
cliniques
inappropriée voir des viandes nous avons
dans les suites convoqué l'ensemble des
administrateurs de cette i hachu en leur
imposant la mise en place d'un plan de
redressement sur la base des conclusions
de cette enquête
IGAS igesr comme vous je déplore ce
nouvel épisode
inadmissible de cette affaire sachant
que la justice est en train de suivre
son cours comme vous avez pu le
constater avec moi dès ce matin devant
cette publication qui pourrait cette
proposition de publication qui pour moi
s'apparente a de la provocation nous
serons amenés et l'étude est en cours
avec les services juridique apprendre
avec ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau pour
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
et moi-même toutes les mesures
nécessaires envers l'ensemble des
signatures de cet article je vous
remercie merci monsieur jaumier
monsieur le ministre je pense que
vous-même avec conscience de la
faiblesse de votre réponse
il y a deux ans
les alertes étaient déjà nombreuses les
rapports de la NSM les rapports de
ligase et bien avant en 2015 l'Inserm
quitté le conseil d'administration de
l'iachu Méditerranée
café l'Université d'Aix-Marseille pour
mettre fin à ses dérives rien
qu'avez-vous fait messieurs les
ministres monsieur Véran vous étiez
ministre de la Santé vous n'avez pas
répondu à la question écrite que j'ai
déposée concernant les dérives de l'IHU
madame Frédéric Vidal ministre de la
Recherche n'a pas répondu non plus à mes
questions et bien si l'ensemble des
institutions de notre pays et les
ministres se sont tu et on fait preuve
des faiblesses c'est peut-être parce que
le chef de l'État et allait couvrir de
sa chaleureuse immunité le patron de
l'IHU et c'est un dysfonctionnement
grave de nos institutions
merci chers collègues la parole la
parole est maintenant Monsieur Bernard
fialer pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole chers collègues merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche et une fois les portes coutume
dans cette hémicycle je voudrais parler
d'amour
l'amour en général passe par l'amour de
la langue qui n'est ni nationaliste ni
conservateur mais qui exige des preuves
et des épreuves on ne fait pas n'importe
quoi avec la langue ces mots de Jacques
derida sont repris par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Pape Ndiaye dans
le rapport au Parlement sur la langue
française
et pourtant le 10 mai 2023 à
l'Université Lyon 2 l'énoncé d'un examen
de licence en droit était rédigé dans un
langage inclusif excessif par son
intégriste 12 avec un Z à la place de
tous alt pour il ou elle mais aussi
professionnel appel à eux reconnu
ouverte aussi incompréhensible pourtant
la langue de la République est le
français essentielle à notre lien social
pour Michelin même l'identité de la
France c'est sa langue d'ailleurs à
l'article 2 de la Constitution il est
écrit la langue de la République et le
français
tous les citoyens ont ainsi le droit
démocratique garanti par la loi de
recevoir une information et de
s'exprimer dans leur langue la loi tout
bon affirme le droit aux Français pour
que l'ensemble de la société puisse se
comprendre et échanger et plus loin
d'ailleurs dans l'enseignement et la
recherche c'est la langue de
l'enseignement des examens et concours
ainsi que des thèses et mémoires il
s'agit de redonner à ce cas de légal
toute sa dimension politique et d'agir
pour maintenir son efficacité ces mots
sont dans le rapport au Parlement la
circulaire du 6 mai 2021 adressé au
personnel de l'éducation nationale
énoncent les mêmes principes pour les
actes administratifs et les pratiques
d'enseignement madame la ministre à
l'université dans le respect absolu de
la liberté académique à laquelle nous
veillons tous que pouvez-vous faire pour
que la liberté de penser d'innover de
créer se fasse avec le vocabulaire du
dictionnaire officiel de l'Académie
française qui n'est pas figée il mérite
chaque année merci
au journal d'une caisse
la parole est à Madame Sylvie retaillot
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur à
recherche
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs merci beaucoup d'abord pour
votre question excusez-moi d'abord je
voudrais me permettre de compléter juste
pour rappeler deux éléments importants
sur le cas de normatif vous en avez
rappelé dans lequel nous nous plaçons
effectivement le premier c'est la
circulaire de 2017 du Premier ministre
de l'époque Édouard Philippe sur les
règles de féminisation qui s'appliquent
aux actes de nature juridique et au
texte administratif et il le dit
clairement dans un souci de clarté et
d'intelligibilité immédiate de ces
documents autant d'impératif auxquels je
suis auquel nous sommes également
attachés donc en espèces elles ne
s'applique pas au sujet d'examen
effectivement car dans l'enseignement
supérieur vous l'avez dit les
enseignants chercheurs sont entièrement
libres quand ton sujet de leurs cours
mais aussi de leur sujet d'examen et de
leur formulation l'université pas plus
que le ministère effectivement vous
l'avez dit sur la la liberté académique
n'exerce directement de contrôle ni sur
les sujets ni sur le contenu pédagogique
des enseignements sauf en cas de propos
diffamatoires injurieux ou
discriminatoire donc juste pour appeler
dans le cas de Lyon sur lequel vous
m'interrogez effectivement l'épreuve en
droit de la famille proposait un choix
entre deux sujets qui permettait l'un
comme l'autre d'aborder une épreuve du
droit de la famille toutes deux traités
dans le cadre des enseignements
dispensés mais si l'un des deux sujets
proposés a été rédigé dans une forme
d'écriture dite inclusive et je n'en
dirai pas plus que ce que vous avez
décrit l'autre était effectivement
parfaitement classique cela étant si
votre question est encouragez-vous
l'usage de l'écriture dit inclusive dans
les sujets d'examens ou contrôle ou tout
document sous forme utilisant des points
médian ou des mots comme vous l'avez
prononcé ma réponse est clairement NON
et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
il se trouve que je suis comme vous et
je croise beaucoup d'entre nous ici
afficher à notre belle langue il se
trouve que je suis aussi très attentif
aux questions de représentation c'est
pourquoi notre langue est suffisamment
riche pour s'exprimer sans véhiculer de
stéréotypes de genre et c'est pourquoi
nous développons les guides pour pouvoir
aider et pouvoir ne pas tomber dans
cette caricature par rapport aux examens
je vous remercie
vraiment orateur ou réponse des deux
minutes deux minutes c'est pas deux
minutes 25 2 minutes 30 monsieur le
rapporteur général Jean-François Huchon
à la parole pour le groupe les
républicain
madame la ministre 2022 année record en
matière de saisie de drogue mais 2022
forcée de le reconnaître c'est aussi une
montée inexorable de la violence liée au
trafic de drogue c'est aujourd'hui un
phénomène qui gangrène nos territoires
des grandes villes en passant par les
villes petites et moyennes mais même
aussi les territoires locaux qui
subissent aujourd'hui une spirale de
réglement de compte avec utilisation
d'armes à feu et bien sûr
fusillade Le Creusot Carpentras
mais aussi Orléans Chambéry Valence à
mort et dans mon département de
Meurthe-et-Moselle Villerupt 5 blessés
dont trois blessés graves
madame la ministre comment l'État
répond-il aux appels à l'aide des
populations et des élus locaux face à
ces populations qui d'ailleurs sont
souvent sous l'emprise d'une forme de
terreur quels moyens déployer en terme
de surveillance de force de protection
et de sécurité et dans une zone police
comme celle de Villerupt quel plan
d'action concret comptez-vous mettre en
œuvre
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à Madame Dominique Faure
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales la ruralité
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général
on partage le constat je vous demande de
bien vouloir excuser monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des premières
chair altermanais en déplacement en
Nouvelle-Calédonie les villes que vous
avez citées dans votre département on
fait l'objet d'une fusillade j'étais
moi-même ici
en échange avec vous-même ou un de vos
collègues il y a 15 jours sur ce sujet
le ministre de l'Intérieur s'est mis en
capacité de se mobiliser immédiatement à
tout acte de violence liée à des trafics
de stupéfiants que cela soit dans les
quartiers des grandes villes où dans les
villes de taille moyenne un effort
significatif a été fait sur les renforts
policiers avec des ouvertures de poste
importantes lors du mouvement général
2023 plus 11 postes ouverts pour la CSP
de Longwy dont dépend la commune de
Villerupt et plus 44 postes ouverts sur
le département du Meurthe-et-Moselle de
la Meurthe-et-Moselle ces efforts
s'inscrivent dans une dynamique plus
globale avec notamment une augmentation
de 8500 postes pour la police nationale
et la gendarmerie nationale sur cinq ans
grâce à la loop me par ailleurs une
concertation permanente avec les élus
locaux étaient mises en place je vous
l'avais dit elle a eu lieu le 26 mai le
préfet reçu des élus
demeurthe-et-moselle afin d'échanger sur
les différents axes d'amélioration
possible pour la sécurité du territoire
plusieurs propositions ont été mises sur
la table et vont faire l'objet de
nouveaux échanges avec les élus lors
d'une réunion place Beauvau le 5 juin
l'ensemble des préfets je le rappelle
sont à la disposition des élus pour
adapter les dispositifs de sécurité aux
enjeux et notamment pour garantir la
mise en oeuvre des instances locales de
sécurité mais pour mettre en oeuvre les
financements de la vidéoprotection par
exemple je vous remercie merci monsieur
le rapporteur général
madame la ministre
finalement
j'assistais à la réunion du 26 mai mais
vous savez ce que vous venez de dire ça
fait plus d'une décennie qu'avec des
gouvernements successifs ces éléments
sont donnés mais finalement les
effectifs de police ne sont jamais à la
hauteur aujourd'hui à Villerupt Longwy
70 personnels là où il en faudrait 95 78
personnels où il en faudrait 95 annonce
du ministre avec effectivement des
arrivées mais c'est des arrivées de
personnes qui vont être remplacées par
autant de départ ça n'est pas si je vous
le dis ça n'est pas sérieux ce que nous
demandons aujourd'hui c'est de prendre
en compte la gravité de la situation
faut-il attendre des événements encore
plus graves pour que aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales l'état
sachent mobiliser nous comptons sur
l'état merci monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est maintenant Madame
Florence blatrice compta pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et République vous
avez la parole mes collègues merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues aujourd'hui partout
en France les enseignants manifestent le
refus du pacte que votre gouvernement
propose car le compte n'y est pas loin
de là est loin notamment de la promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron d'augmenter de 10 %
tous les enseignants en septembre
prochain l'éducation nationale vit une
véritable crise d'évocation le nombre
d'inscrits au concours en 2023 est en
edès par rapport à 2021 et les
démissions ainsi que les ruptures
conventionnelles ont été multipliées par
5 la dégradation des conditions de
travail et du pouvoir d'achat en sont
les principales causes l'enjeu de cette
revalorisation aurait donc dû concerner
la partie socle c'est-à-dire
inconditionnel mais en réalité elle est
loin de rattraper les baisses de poire
d'achat de 15 à 25% de ces vins de ces
20 dernières années ni de rivaliser avec
nos voisins européens alors qu'un
enseignant débutait sa carrière à 2,2 SM
dans les années 90 il est toujours dit à
1,2 SMIC la rémunération des enseignants
est inférieure de 15% à ceux de l'OCDE
et je ne parle pas de nos voisins
allemands c'est donc cette enveloppe
socle qu'il faut avoir le courage
d'augmenter fortement et qu'il faut
traduire par un relèvement des points
d'indice et non par des primes quant à
la part d'augmentation en échange
mission supplémentaires elle n'est en
aucun cas une revalorisation salariale
c'est une provocation alors même que les
enseignants français travaillent
davantage que leurs homologues européens
avec davantage d'élèves ça contribuera à
dégrader encore les conditions
d'enseignement c'est le retour du
travail plus pour gagner plus allez-vous
madame la ministre entendre les
enseignants et assurer à tous les
personnels une augmentation salariale
sans contrepartie qui rattrape les
pertes de pouvoir d'achat et qui
traduisent la considération de la nation
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
madame Carole Grandjean ministre délégué
chargé de l'enseignement et une
formation professionnelle merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Béatrice
blatix compta je vous rappelle que le
pacte enseignant est l'un des deux
volets que le gouvernement s'est engagé
à mettre en œuvre pour revaloriser le
métier d'enseignant ainsi que sa
rémunération pour rendre ce métier plus
attractif nous sommes face à un enjeu
crucial de mise à niveau des
rémunérations et de recrutement des
professeurs pour les prochaines années
sur la revalorisation inconditionnelle
qui va bénéficier donc à tous les
enseignants ainsi que monsieur le
Président de la République c'était
engagé à compter de la rentrée prochaine
tous les nouveaux professeurs titulaires
débuteront à plus de 2000 euros nets par
mois par ailleurs l'ensemble des
professeurs connaîtront une augmentation
de mensuel de leur rémunération nette de
95 allant jusqu'à plus de 200 euros ce
sont ainsi 850 000 professeurs et
personnels d'éducation et d'orientation
qui vont bénéficier de cette
augmentation cette revalorisation de
tous représente deux tiers de
l'enveloppe globale et inédite de 3
milliards d'euros inscrites au budget du
ministère à cette augmentation
inconditionnelle s'ajoutera uniquement
pour les professeurs volontaires
j'insiste sur ce point une rémunération
supplémentaire en contrepartie de
mission complémentaires chaque mission
sera indemnisée de 250 euros brut par an
un professeur pouvant choisir plusieurs
missions ainsi par exemple un professeur
qui choisira trois missions sera
rémunéré en plus de sa rémunération de
base à hauteur de 3750 euros brut par an
pour le cas des lycées professionnels
pour lesquels j'ai engagé une réforme
d'ampleur la rémunération des
professeurs volontaires pour ce pacte
sera un forfait annuel de 7500 euros
brut l'objectif est donc clair il ne
s'agit d'une demande imposée à toutes un
quelconque travaillait plus pour gagner
plus mais bien pour toutes les missions
complémentaires de un service public de
l'éducation plus efficace pour nos
élèves et de valoriser l'engagement des
enseignants je vous remercie merci
Madame l'adresse Conca une dizaine de
secondes
n'avait pas pris la mesure de la
situation nos enseignants méritent une
juste revalorisation salariale votre
réforme n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux elle va au contraire des
organisés notre système scolaire et
dégrader les conditions de travail merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur
Étienne blanc pour le groupe les
républicain merci monsieur le président
et madame la Première ministre et le
tribunal administratif de Grenoble le 11
mai a rendu une décision par laquelle il
annule le règlement de l'Institut des
langues de l'Université de Grenoble
parce que il fut écrit en écriture
inclusive utilisant à la fois le point
médian et le langage de genre
le tribunal l'explique clairement que ce
règlement est illisible et qu'en tout
cas il n'est pas écrit en français et il
n'est pas conforme à la Constitution
quelques jours après et dans une
interview Figaro Madame la Ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui est quand même en charge
de former nos élites
explique que finalement au titre des
libertés académiques on peut accepter
l'écriture inclusive alors madame la
Première ministre mais qui faut-il
croire le président de la République
qui a Villers
le temple de l'écriture et de la langue
française avec affirmé que c'était un
véritable trésor qui fait le protéger où
faut-il croire vos MInistres qui
s'explique à l'envie que finalement on
peut accepter l'écriture inclusive qui
détruit la langue française
merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses
pour vos réponses la parole est à Madame
Sylvie Retailleau ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci monsieur
le sénateur blanc
qui déjà de me donner l'occasion de
repréciser je sais excusez-moi mais
il y a un sénateur
de me donner le l'occasion de repréciser
non comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
ne suis pas pour l'utilisation de
l'écriture inclusive je crois que vous
avez et c'est pour ça que ça me donne
l'occasion quand on explique de
l'écriture exclusive avec des points
médian ou bien comme ça a été redit tout
à l'heure des exemples qui sont proches
non respect de la langue française mais
quand on dit cher tout et tous ce que
j'appelais l'expression et c'est
d'inclure l'ensemble c'est très
différent de l'inclature inclusive et
cela me donne l'occasion et je vous en
remercie de leur expliquer tout d'abord
monsieur le sénateur je vous sais très
attaché au liberté académique dont on
parle aussi ici par rapport au sujet de
Lyon puisque effectivement le cas de
Grenoble tombe sous la coupe de la
circulaire et donc le tribunal
administratif a rendu vous le savez vous
l'avez rappelé dans le cadre de vos
travaux avec le sénateur gâteau lin sur
les ingérences étrangères on ne peut pas
être pour la liberté académique
l'autonomie des université et fustigé
continuellement le ministère pour qu'il
intervienne à tout bout de champ pour
régir le contenu de ce que propose les
enseignants et les enseignants
chercheurs je voudrais juste rappeler
pourquoi cette liberté académique est
importante ce qui nous empêche pas de
donner effectivement des consignes
clairs en nous appuyant sur les
circulaires qui existent pour pouvoir
respecter la langue française comme on
se doit de la respecter et avoir des
sujets des examens et en enseignement au
niveau d'une langue intelligible et
claire ce qui est important je vous
rejoins là dessus pour l'enseignement de
tous nos étudiants je vous remercie
merci Monsieur blanc
oui merci le moins qu'on puisse dire
madame la ministre c'est que votre
réponse est quelque peu ambigu en tout
cas elle n'est pas claire et d'abord
vous ne répondez pas
au dispositif au jugement du tribunal de
Grenoble sur l'inintelligibilité et
surtout sur le problème constitutionnel
et puis vous ne répondez pas l'Académie
française qui en matière d'écluses
d'écriture inclusive parle d'un péril
mortifère et elle parle d'une aberration
alors Camus disait tout le malheur des
hommes provient du fait qu'il ne tienne
pas un langage clair et bien moi
j'invite aujourd'hui le gouvernement à
tenir un langage clair l'écriture
inclusive c'est oui ou c'est non si
c'est non décidé enfin que tout texte de
quelques natures qu'il soit écrit en
écriture inclusive est nul de plein
droit et là vous tiendrez un langage
clair merci
la parole
et maintenant à Monsieur Michel
canevêque pour le groupe Union centriste
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
la première ministre a présenté voilà 10
jours le les pistes du gouvernement
concernant la transition écologique et
elle a annoncé qu'un plan d'action
serait proposé à la fin juin bien
entendu monsieur le Président nous
sommes tous attachés à la transition
écologique et en particulier pour aller
vers une énergie de plus en plus
décarbonée mais il nous semble important
de tenir compte à la fois des réalités
économiques à la fois des réalités
territoriales des réalités sociales
ainsi nous sommes particulièrement
inquiets concernant le projet
d'interdiction d'installation de
chaudière à gaz parce qu'il est
transparé dans les propos que cela
pourrait survenir or aujourd'hui plus
d'un logement sur 4 a comme mode de
d'énergie le gaz il est donc important
de tenir compte de cela et je souhaitais
connaître les intentions réelles du
gouvernement à cet égard
pour vos réponses la parole est à Madame
Agnès panière une hachée ministre de la
transition énergétique
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur canivé le président
de la République nous a fixé un objectif
clair en matière de transition
énergétique être le premier pays
industriel assortir des énergies
fossiles et c'est une condition si nous
voulons atteindre la neutralité
climatique d'ici 2050 ce défi est
immense vous le savez nous ne pouvons le
réussir que grâce à la mobilisation de
chacun d'entre nous c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement travaille sous l'égide de
la première ministre à des feuilles de
route secteur par secteur pour
décarboner et notamment évidemment sur
le secteur du bâtiment et du logement et
vous le savez dans le bâtiment 47% des
émissions de CO2 si on regarde l'usage
du bâtiment ce sont ces liés au
chauffage au gaz alors on le sait
réduire les énergies fossiles dans ces
logements c'est réduire la facture c'est
réduire notre dépendance à des énergies
importées
et donc augmenter notre souveraineté et
c'est agir contre le dérèglement
climatique ce mouvement il n'est pas
nouveau puisque les dispositifs appris
brenoff permettent aujourd'hui déjà
d'accompagner les Français qui
souhaitent changer de chaudière et avoir
une chaudière non fossible et nous avons
également pris une mesure importante qui
est ne pas permettre l'installation de
chauffage au gaz dans les bâtiments
neufs nous allons continuer à travailler
c'est tout l'objet de la concertation
que je vais lancer avec mes collègues
Christophe Béchu et Olivier Klein pour
faire en sorte de trouver par
anticipation et en nous projetant dans
la durée les meilleures solutions
permettant à la fois de construire les
filières alternatives à au chauffage à
gaz et vous savez que nous avons des
positions non négligeables sur les
pompes à chaleur par exemple mais
également de faire en sorte que les
Français ou qu'ils soient sur le
territoire et quel que soit leur type de
logement puisse être accompagnés dans
l'évolution de leur mode de chauffage et
au final pour tenir nos trajectoires de
baisse de gaz conditions de de à effet
de serre je sais que vous y êtes
particulièrement attaché nous lancerons
donc prochainement cette concertation et
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour le
faire de manière pragmatique éduquer
mais pour ne pas perdre de vue l'envie
l'ambition climatique que nous portons
monsieur canevêque et lui seul monsieur
le Président je comprends et je partage
cette ambition d'économie des carbonée
madame la ministre mais je dois rendre
le gouvernement attentif au fait que
nous ne pouvons nous contenter d'une
seule source d'énergie je veux dire par
là qu'il faut qu'il y ait un mix
énergétique qui permette d'assurer la
réelle souveraineté de notre pays en
s’est aperçu cet hiver que de se reposer
sur la seule situation de l'électricité
pour tous les usages nous amener à
quelques déconvenues et donc il importe
que dès à présent nous prenions bien
cela en compte et sur les territoires
ruraux en particulier on sait bien que
nous avons des foyers qui ont des moyens
très limités et on sait que la
production de gaz renouvelable peut
apporter à la fois des solutions
économiques à notre pays mais aussi des
solutions intelligentes pour
l'énergie de nos territoires donc soyons
attentifs à cela
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Christina plucher pour
le groupe les républicains
merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues aujourd'hui
l'actualité de mon département l'heure
me conduit à évoquer l'exclusion des
enfants porteurs de handicap à prise en
charge complète en l'occurrence certains
cas d'autisme auquel la République ne
garantit pas un droit décent à
l'éducation d'ailleurs le 17 avril la
France a été condamnée par le Comité des
droits sociaux du Conseil de l'Europe
pourtant de nombreux budgets ont été mis
sur la table depuis des années le virage
de l'inclusion a été engagé et tant
mieux mais je crains madame la ministre
qu'on soit passé d'une extrême à l'autre
inclure qu'on la prise en charge est
compliquée ce n'est pas laissé ses
enfants à domicile pendant plusieurs
années avec un saupoudrage
d'intervenants ponctuels attend très
partiel générant la rupture
professionnelle d'un parent et sa
précarité économique
inclure ce n'est pas hyper trop fier les
moyens alloués à la commitologie et à la
concertation aux dépens de la création
effective de place en structure
d'éducation adaptée inclure c'est
comprendre que le milieu dit protégé à
toute sa place parmi les propositions
comme lieu d'expertise au bénéfice des
enfants dont la prise en charge est la
plus complexe alors madame la ministre
qu'avez-vous prévu pour résorber le
problème de l'embouteillage dans les
instituts médicaux-éducatifs pour la
rentrée prochaine quelle solution digne
allez vous proposer à ses parents
désespérés qui en sont même à se mettre
en grève de la faim
et qu'elle voit de financement allez
vous mettre en oeuvre pour sortir des
éternels effets d'annonces et fléchis
enfin les budgets vers la création de
place supplémentaires
madame la mise ses enfants ne sont pas
des enfants de la République à temps
partiel ils ont comme les autres le
droit à une éducation à ton complet
merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à Madame
Geneviève Darius sec ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice pucher je vous
remercie de votre question elle va me
permettre de faire un point
effectivement j'ai rencontré aujourd'hui
le maire de pose dans votre département
et il a des préoccupations très
légitimes de papa mais il a aussi porté
il porte aussi le sujet plus global de
famille qui sont comme lui dans des
impasses
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les cols inclusives c'est
430000 enfants inclus dans l'école de la
République mais les IME c'est 1140e sur
notre territoire national pour 71000
places les places animées n'ont jamais
été supprimés n'ont jamais été diminué
et ont toujours continué à évoluer il
faut savoir que sur ces 71 000 places à
nieme il y a de façon anormale 10000
places occupées par des adultes sous
amendement Creton qui reste dans ses ime
notre première mission doit être avec
les départements chaque département de
travailler efficacement et concrètement
à faire en sorte de trouver des
solutions différentes pour ces adultes
afin de redonner de la capacité à saisir
eux de pouvoir accueillir des enfants
car la place des enfants c'est dans des
établissements pour enfants
deuxièmement il y a des territoires dans
notre pays qui sont en manque de
solution et ça nous les avons bien
identifié il y a une vingtaine de
département environ et nous allons
travailler prioritairement à proposer
des nouvelles solutions des nouvelles
places ou solutions dans ces
départements et enfin il y a des
handicaps particuliers et complexes
comme vous le disiez qui nécessite aussi
de porter des solutions nouvelles la
Conférence Est nationale du handicap a
donné l'occasion aux présidents de la
République de s'engager sur 50 nouvelles
50 000 pardon nouvelle place et
solutions pour la France entière et
c'est dans ce contexte là que nous
allons déployer cela c'est un effort
majeur de millions d'euros de plus sur
nos budgets et que nous déploions sur
les cinq prochaines années merci Madame
Pluchet oui merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en effet la Coupe du monde
de football féminin va se dérouler de 20
juillet au 20 août prochain or à ce jour
aucun accord n'a été trouvé avec les
diffuseurs éventuels pour sa
retransmission TV en France l'appel
d'offres concernée n'est toujours pas
abouti cette réalité devient
préoccupante appréciation confirmée par
le président de la FIFA organisatrice de
l'événement je cite si les offres
continuent à ne pas être équitables nous
serons contraint de ne pas diffuser la
Coupe du Monde féminine dans les cinq
grands pays européens je précise que les
revenus ainsi générés sont redistribués
intégralement pour le développement du
sport féminin et que les chaînes
françaises étaient engagées à davantage
favoriser le sport féminin l'enjeu de la
Coupe du Monde 2023 est capitale et la
non retransmission de match de notre
équipe nationale l'une des meilleures
elle fait partie du top 5 mondial serait
d'autant plus incompréhensible que la
dernière édition
organiser en France en 2019 et avait
remporté un succès dépassant toutes les
prévisions ainsi le match de quart de
finale avait-il avait-il connu le score
d'audience le plus élevé de toute
l'année 2019 pour TF1 et 4 ans plus tard
cette équipe serait laissée à l'abandon
par tous les diffuseurs potentiels avec
la loi du 2 mars 2022 visa démocratisé
le sport le Parlement a voté la
possibilité de créer une société
commerciale visage et républicaissement
des droits audiovisuels du sport
professionnel pour l'heure seul le
football est concerné il serait
paradoxal que parallèlement à cette
démarche la dimension féminine de cette
activité s'est exclue des bénéfices
financiers escomptés lors d'un grand
événement international il y va
symboliquement de la promotion de
l'affirmation et du financement du sport
féminin l'enjeu et la lutte contre
toutes les formes de discrimination
faisant obstacles à l'émancipation de la
femme par le sport pouvez-vous indiquer
si à ce stade il y a lieu de rester
optimiste quand ça s'est retransmissions
en un mot la France sera-t-elle privée
de Coupe du Monde Féminine enfin le
décret de décembre 2004 listant les 21
événements d'importance majeurs doit-il
être élargi à l'ensemble des matchs des
équipes de France de football et de
rugby masculine et féminine et si oui
dans quel délai Merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau démocratique
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs c'est natrices
vous l'avez dit en 2019 nous étions 12
millions de téléspectateurs pour
encourager l'équipe de France féminine
de football face au Brésil 12 millions
ça crée beaucoup de vocations et on a
besoin de montrer ces images de
sportives de haute compétition pour
donner envie aussi à notre jeunesse de
faire du sport qu'elle soit féminine ou
masculine il y aura dans 50 jours le
début de la Coupe du Monde féminine de
football à nouveau c'est du côté je
crois de l'Australie et la
Nouvelle-Zélande pour ne pas dire de
bêtises et nous voulons évidemment que
les Françaises les Français puissent
regarder la France nous l'espérons en
finale le 20 août prochain de cette
Coupe du monde
à l'initiative de la France mais aussi
de l'Allemagne de l'Italie de l'Espagne
de l'Angleterre au temps de pays
européens passionnés de football comme
chacun sait la ministre des sports dont
j'excuse l'absence parce qu'elle est
actuellement pour un événement des J-100
de la Coupe du monde de rugby cette
fois-ci la mise à sport Amélie ou des
accastera a rédige un communiqué commun
avec ses homologues européens à
destination de la FIFA des annonceurs
pour dire sa volonté qu'un accord puisse
être trouvé de manière à ce que la Coupe
du Monde féminine de football puisse
bien être diffusé dans notre pays ainsi
que dans l'ensemble des pays européens
passionnés de football elle a pris
l'engagement elle l'a dit ce matin qu'il
une solution sera trouvée pour ce faire
par ailleurs monsieur le sénateur
j'insiste avec vous sur la nécessité de
diffuser du sport féminin aujourd'hui
c'est que 5% du sport diffusés sur la
télévision qui concerne le sport féminin
or le sport féminin est un sport de
qualité d'excellence et qui fait rêver
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
maintenant Madame Florence lasarade pour
le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le miniature temporaire des services
d'urgence et de maternité se multiplient
en raison des difficultés de recrutement
médical ainsi en l'espace d'un mois le
service des urgences du centre
hospitalier de Sainte-Foy-la-Grande a
été fermée à 4 prises ce qui correspond
à une durée de 17 jours au total les
services d'urgence d'Arcachon et la
maternité de Langon ne sont pas plus
épargnés ces fermetures temporaires ne
se limitent pas au département de la
Gironde et touche l'ensemble du
territoire ces arrêts sont beaucoup plus
prégnants sur les territoires ruraux on
cause le manque de médecin de médecins
accrue par la mise en oeuvre de la loi
Rice qui plafonne la rémunération des
médecins intérimaires or on constate
déjà
14000 décès supplémentaires par an dans
les zones rurales par rapport aux villes
par ailleurs de 2012 à 2019 on observe
une augmentation de 7% de la mortalité
infantile ainsi en l'espace d'une
décennie la France est passée du
deuxième au 25e rang européen
cette dégradation à l'armante de notre
système de santé est inacceptable votre
gouvernement culpabilise les médecins en
laissant penser qu'ils sont responsables
de la situation ce matin j'ai appris que
la chef de service d'une de ces
structures en poste de plus de plus de
depuis plus de 30 ans vient de faire une
tentative de suicide ce que vivent les
médecins est inhumain ils ne sont pas là
pour pallier les insuffisances du
système c'est votre responsabilité nous
connaissons des difficultés de
recrutement et de fidélisation des
praticiens hospitaliers en raison d'un
manque d'attractivité le constat est
sans appel aujourd'hui 30% des postes de
praticien hospitalier sont vacances et
du jamais vu monsieur le ministre il
faut remettre de l'attractivité pour la
médecine hospitalière nous avons le
devoir collectif de renverser cette
situation quelle solution pérenne
proposez-vous pour pallier les
difficultés de recrutement médical et
éviter la multiplication des fermetures
temporaires des services d'urgence et
des maternités
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur François borne ministre de la
Santé de la prévention merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice la Sarrade
effectivement les difficultés de notre
système de santé sont accusés dans les
services avec plus forte pénibilité en
particulier la pénibilité des gardes de
nuit donc faites bien de signifier les
services d'urgence et les maternités des
maternités cumulant en plus la
difficulté d'avoir trois spécialités
pour pouvoir assurer un fonctionnement
en maternité les gynécovéticiens
anesthésiteraient animateurs et pédiatre
ces difficultés sont connues ces
difficultés ne sont pas nouvelles et je
ne peux pas vous laisser dire que
l'intérim en tout cas la
justifier lutte contre les dérives de
l'intérim médical qui est en train
d'assécher complètement nos hôpitaux
soit responsables de la situation
actuelle nous avons au contraire passé
ces difficultés pendant le mois d'avril
et le mois de mai et maintenant nous
avons la visibilité de ce qui se passe
réellement sur notre territoire comme je
m'y étais en nous trouvons des solutions
certes alternatives sur l'ensemble des
territoires pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
difficultés dans le cadre des parcours
de soins je vous rejoins lorsque vous
dites que ces difficultés ne sont pas
nouvelles et sont anciennes elles sont
en particulier du à des difficultés du
nombre de personnels médical je ne
rappellerai pas le numerus clausus parce
que forte heureusement le gouvernement
précédent a levé cette barrière du
numérique clausus qui quoi qu'on en dise
nous permet aujourd'hui d'avoir 15% de
médecins en plus qui vont sortir de nos
facultés dans quelques années la
solution elle est globalement sur trois
principes un principe d'éthique c'est
comme ça qu'on reconstruit notre système
et c'est ça la lutte contre les dérives
de l'intérim et d'autres luttes
financière un principe d'équipe à
l'échelle de l'équipe de chaque service
que l'on peut reconstruire et un
principe de territoire la responsabilité
territoriale a été mise en place au
niveau des hôpitaux pendant ces travaux
contre les dérives de l'intérim et la
fonctionné elle fonctionne encore pour
assurer la meilleure réponse à nos
concitoyens et je profite des dernières
secondes pour préciser qu'en ce concerne
l'aide médicale urgente c'est-à-dire des
urgences vitales qui est un sujet que je
connais bien celle-ci reste garantie sur
l'ensemble du territoire national je
vous remercie merci Madame la Sarah 10
secondes monsieur Miss vous ne répondez
pas à ma question le président de la
République promet aux Français le
désengorgement des urgences d'ici fin
2024 mais tant que les personnels
soignants ne sont pas rémunérés à
hauteur de leur engagement de leur
responsabilité le désengorgement des
urgences restera une belle promesse
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Lana tétouani pour le groupe Union
centriste c'est le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer monsieur
le ministre depuis quelques mois je suis
continuellement interpellé par mon
compatriotes polynésien sur les délais
d'obtention d'un passeport
dans un territoire comme le mien ainsi
pour tous ceux situés hors zone
européenne détenir un passeport à jour
est une condition essentielle pour se
déplacer mais l'obtenir relève
aujourd'hui du parcours du combattant
nous connaissons aussi les difficultés
rencontrées évoquées à l'échelon
national mais pour nos citoyens
ultramarins situés si loin du centre
dédié allez laboration des passeports ma
question est la suivante
quelle mesure combien de t-il d'adopter
d'adapter pour des délais plus
raisonnables dans l'obtention et la
cheminement de passeport en outre-mer
merci
pour vos réponses la parole de Madame
Dominique fort ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales de la
ruralité merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice et Lana tétouani
je me demande de bien vouloir excuser
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur des
Outre-mer qui d'ailleurs est un autre
maire pour vous dire et vous le savez
que les délais de délivrance des
passeports et des cartes d'identité à
augmenter énormément avec l'augmentation
du nombre de demandes on est passé de 9
millions en 2021 à 12 millions 2022 à 15
millions actuellement donc nous mettons
des moyens très importants nous avons
encore renforcé ces moyens pour
raccourcir ses délais à la demande de
Madame la première ministre il y a
exactement un mois mais
les délais en Polynésie sont
particulièrement
satisfaisant ils sont
alors pourquoi je suis sûr je suis sûr
parce que on est à 30 jours chez vous on
est à 30 jours chez vous on est encore
en moyenne à 50 jours on était à 70
jours il y a deux mois donc les délais
moyen baissent mais les délais en
Polynésie vous avez 18 dispositifs de
recueil et en étant en train d'en mettre
un 19e donc les délaiss soient trop
longs et même un mois avant que vous
trouviez que ce soit trop long je suis
d'accord avec vous nous y travaillons
nous portons l'objectif de les baisser
très significativement d'ici l'été
cependant je demande d'entendre que
les collectivités locales et le préfet
en Polynésie fait un travail remarquable
qui fait que le délai est très bas merci
madame t'étonner je suis sûr que vous
allez dire votre ravissement allez-y
madame la fenêtre madame la ministre je
vous remercie mais je vais être gentille
aujourd'hui je vous pardonnerai je vous
excuserai mais pas la méconnaissance
mais totale
de ce qui se passe dans nos
collectivités
ultramarines si je m'exprime aujourd'hui
c'est parce que il y a un problème si
tout allait bien je me tirais mais c'est
pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas
parce que là où je vous interpelle
aujourd'hui à l'approche des grandes
vacances scolaires pour tous ceux et
toutes celles qui veulent rentrer dans
nos collectivités il y aura la rentrée
universitaire au mois de septembre pour
tous nos étudiants qui viendront
poursuivre les études ici
en France en fait quoi non on dit plus
métropole on dit hexagone aujourd'hui
d'après l'Assemblée nationale mais on
fait quoi
les services de l'État les services du
haut-commissaire précisément en
Polynésie française quand les appels
qu'est-ce qu'ils nous disent qu'est-ce
qu'ils disent à la scénariste
il y a trop de demandes on y peut rien
ils font attendre mais c'est environ
d'entendre ça en 2023
c'est environ
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les prochaines questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement auront lieu
le mercredi 7 juin à 15h je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h30 pour le débat sur le bilan de
l'application des lois la séance est
suspendue